as now with reaction two of the stars
from today's hearing Ohio Congressman
Jim Jordan and House Judiciary ranking
member should be the senator elect from
the great state of Georgia in my humble
opinion dumb decision by the governor of
the state of Georgia of a lot of friends
there you did a great job today
thank you very much ranking member
Collins I will I will I will defer to
your rank here there is no fact
witnesses we had three people that hate
Donald Trump they've expressed their
opinions repeatedly radical viewpoints
why were they even there well they were
there because Jerry Nadler had to figure
out something to do he has no plan as I
said today the clock in the calendar not
the facts are driving this Shawn and
look we you know we show today Jim
Jordan Matt gasps John Ratcliffe we just
blew holes in it because it's so easy we
have the facts on our side
all they have is hatred of President
Trump all they have is not liking a man
who came to office to do what he said he
was going to do and he's actually doing
it when you got facts on your side truce
on your side it'll win every time you
know Jim Jordan I bet you're probably
glad that that congressman Collins
didn't get the promotion to the upper
chamber that was very but I'm glad ease
worries that as well four facts never
change in Jordan yeah not only that five
meetings after the four facts I don't
think anybody could do it as well as you
do it explained right well you're kind
but I loved your monologue because the
disdain that these people that they
brought in today these professors have
for us regular Americans who voted for
President Trump never forget Sean
seventeen days ago the Speaker of the
House on a Sunday show called the
President of the United States and
impostor the guy who had 63 million
people vote for him the guy who won an
electoral college landslide the Speaker
of the House is calling the President of
the United States an imposter that is
the attitude that was on full display
today from these three witnesses that
the Democrats called in but as Doug said
they had to call him in because they
don't want to talk about those four
facts you just talked about they don't
want to talk about those five meetings
where szalinski met with senior
government officials in the time that
the aid was paused and not one of those
meetings did linking aid to to any type
of investigation come up nah
once so they got no case no facts so
they got to bring in elites who we're
gonna look down their nose at us and say
the kind of things that Professor Carlin
said today about the first family okay
well which was pretty disgusting and
it's pickled we're gonna get into a lot
more on that but this is a key because
there was a very key moments in the ship
show and the ship show there was one
moment when one of your colleagues
actually said you know went through the
entire issue no fact witnesses Matt
gates did a great job on that today also
every there's not one fact witness
except ambassador Sandlin what do you
want nothing no quid pro quo you
followed that up congressman Jordan with
okay well when did they make the
announcement right and and Soglin
explain yeah when did it happen right he
said they were going to get a call they
were going to get a meeting they weren't
going to get the money unless there was
an announcement made by President
Solinsky saying that they were gonna
investigate burr isman the Biden's guess
what they got the call they got the
meeting they got the money and there was
never ever an announcement and the only
thing ever said direct evidence was when
ambassador Cilan told him ask the
president what do you want from ukraine
and what the president say I want
nothing I want no quid pro quo I want
this new guy this new guy who ran on an
anti-corruption platform I want him to
do what he said because I'm talking
about the hard-earned tax dollars of the
American people that's what happened but
the Democrats don't care because they've
been out to get as Doug said they'd be
get out to get this guy from even before
the election when they launched the
Trump Rush investigation in the summer
of 2016
last word congressman Collins do we have
any idea where this goes is Jerry Nadler
given you any heads-up of what's next no
this is really what sad Sean the
American people ought to be outraged
with a waste of taxpayer dollars a waste
of taxpayer time with the shift' show
with the Nadler circus we still have no
idea if you swatch today I gave him an
opportunity in his closing to say where
are we going from here what is your plan
instead of bringing these academics who
don't have anything to do with the show
to bring us actually to have fact
witnesses people who would actually be
able to testify that is not what we got
going on Sean it is just a joke it is a
circus it's off the train off the tracks
and we need to make sure the American
people know that and by the way I'm
gonna play one more plug Adam Schiff
needs to I come out of hiding get get
some courage
backbone and actually come before our
committee and testify if he doesn't he
has no veracity and anything that he's
written senator collins from the great
state of georgia thank you and
Congressman Jim Jordan thanks yeah
thanks god